it's one of the option in things like
this the make up the wings can get in
the way and it's it's beautiful I think
it's I would say it's a benchmark in
prosthetic makeup and would it take
hours would it take hours or the whole
thing took four hours okay so there's a
face it's the fat suit and the clothes
yes and and and but the attention to
detail the the the cigars you you chose
the special cigar I did well I did and I
used to smoke I don't I don't smoke
anymore and I got nicotine poisoning
because I was on about 12 a day I went
through $30,000 of cigars on the set
fifty quid the pop and I I would do two
about twelve of them a days so I got
nicotine but I basically had a bad
stomach for the three months I was I was
on the show and we had a Christmas break
and everybody went off and decorated
their Christmas trees and went out
shopping and I went and had a
colonoscopy
the man who has everything
like every day pretty much there yes
just it was it it was just it was I
think it was the compression in the soup
dehydration the cigars and it was a good
surprise to pay but Wow and can I just
say so because I was really I really
admired what you said about Michael
Jackson I would never forgive myself
Gary if I don't tell you you are one of
the greatest actors to have ever lived
you're one of my inspirations your look
if you have not seen the darkest hour
you will see one of the greatest actors
alive give one of the greatest
performances of one of the Great British
characters of all time it is astonishing
selection of special skills on the show
tonight Gary what is a real treat am i
right to say it's a it's a it's
something physical
yes it's visible yeah I don't know if
it's very special tell us what we're
going to watch or should we just see it
well yes it's somewhat my my wife
actually recorded it on an iPhone in the
trailer and it's Winston Churchill doing
James Brown so here is Winston Churchill
this is so many layers this is so meta
now Gary Coleman does Winston Churchill
doing James Brown for the Oscar